Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour.
Brisons la glace et faisons connaissance.
Vous est-il déjà arrivé d’être embarrassé
par une question anodine ?
Vous savez, celle qu’on pose l’air de
rien, justement pour faire connaissance ?
Êtes-vous marié ?
Avez-vous des enfants ?
Quel âge avez-vous ?
Vous faites quoi dans la vie ?
Moi, il y en avait une
lorsque j’étais enfant
qui m’était particulièrement difficile.
Une de ces questions anodines à laquelle
tout le monde répondait facilement
mais pas moi.
Combien as-tu de frères et sœurs ?
Simple, non ?
Oui, mais pas pour moi.
J'ai longtemps répondu cinq.
Je l'écrivais aussi sur mes fiches
de rentrée scolaire.
Mais le problème, c'est que d'une année
sur l'autre, d'un professeur à l'autre,
ce n’était pas souvent les mêmes réponses,
pas les mêmes noms
et parfois mème pas le même nombre.
Vous vous demandez pourquoi j’avais besoin
de mentir sur une question aussi banale.
Pourquoi ?
C'est simple, j'avais honte.
Honte de dire qu’en réalité,
j’ai 23 frères et sœurs.
Oui, oui, vous avez bien entendu : 23.
Et si je me risquais à le révéler,
un tas de ces questions s’ensuivait.
Sont-ils tous de la même mère ? Non.
Combien de frères ? De sœurs ?
Je n’ai pas compté mais je m’y penche.
Est-ce que vous avez tous vécu ensemble ?
Non plus.
Une dernière.
Votre père est-il polygame ?
Pas officiellement.
Bref, une foultitude de questions
et je devenais cette bête de foire,
cette out of the box,
celle qui ne rentrait pas dans les cases.
J’étais si honteuse,
moi, cette out of the box.
Si honteuse, si humiliée.
Et je n’avais qu’une envie,
de disparaître au fond de mon lit.
Ayant grandi en France,
je reconnais que c’est hors norme.
Jusqu’au jour où j’ai réalisé
que c’était une force.
Ce qui pour les autres était une question
banale, traitée en à peine deux secondes,
était pour moi une aubaine
de faire de cette question,
simplement posée sur la forme,
une réelle argumentation sur ma culture,
mes différences, ma singularité.
Et cerise sur le gâteau, ça m’a même
évité des sujets complexes
en entretien de concours.
Bref, c’est comme ça,
je suis née quelque part.
(Chante) On ne choisit pas ses parents,
on ne choisit pas sa famille.
On ne choisit pas non plus les trottoirs
de Manille, de Paris ou d’Alger
pour apprendre à marcher.
Être né quelque part.
Être né quelque part,
Pour celui qui est né,
c’est toujours un hasard.
(Parle) Un hasard.
Et pour autant, est-ce que cela va
m’empêcher d’arriver là où je veux aller ?
Durant ces quelques minutes,
je vais vous distribuer les cartes
de ce que je crois être les bonnes pour
déjouer les pronostics de sa destinée,
pour devenir ce que nous voulons être,
indépendamment de là où nous sommes.
À n’en pas douter, j’ai eu de
la chance dans mon parcours.
La chance des succès inattendus,
des rendez-vous hasardeux.
Mais cette chance,
n’était-ce qu’une question de chance ?
Ah ça non ! J’ai travaillé d’arrache-pied.
Il n’y a, je crois,
pas de secret à la réussite,
si ce n’est le travail,
l’audace et la ténacité.
Vous êtes issu d’une minorité,
quelle qu’elle soit ?
Vous venez d’un milieu défavorisé ?
Vous êtes une femme comme moi ?
Vous êtes vu comme un fils
à papa, une fille à papa ?
Vous vous sentez out of the box
ou vous êtes vous ?
Simplement vous ?
Eh bien, la recette est la même.
Il vous faudra sans doute doubler
les doses et je sais de quoi je parle.
Rien ne me prédisposait
à la vie que je mène aujourd’hui.
Enchantée.
Je m'appelle Tania Gombert, j'ai 42 ans.
Je suis cadre
dans le secteur des assurances
et j’ai, dès l’âge de 30 ans,
intégré les instances de direction.
Je suis la maman des deux plus
belles petites filles du monde.
Et intelligentes, et sublimes -
et je suis objective.
Je vis avec un homme merveilleux
au sein d’un couple dans lequel je cultive
allègrement mon incompétence ménagère.
Ah oui, j’ai de la chance !
Mais ça n’a pas toujours été ainsi.
Et malgré mon éveil brutal
sur l’inégalité des chances,
je ne crois pas au déterminisme.
Je crois en la détermination.
Non, tout n’est pas joué, tout n’est pas
déterminé dès sa naissance,
de par sa filiation, de par ses gènes
ou de par ses croyances.
Croire en cela, c’est croire
au fatalisme du déterminisme.
Selon vous,
quelle était la destinée
d’une petite fille née à Madagascar
d’une mère jeune, seule et sans un sou ?
Naître à Madagascar,
c’est naître dans l’un des pays
les plus pauvres au monde,
tristement connu pour son tourisme sexuel
et pour la prostitution des jeunes femmes.
Alors je vous le redemande :
quelle était ma destinée ?
Je veux dire aux jeunes,
aux moins jeunes,
finalement, à vous tous, vous un jour qui
avez entendu un « Tu n’y arriveras pas »
ou un autre « Ça n’est pas ta place »,
personne ne va te la donner, ta place.
Cette place, tu la veux ?
Tu y visualises ton épanouissement ?
Alors prends-la, enfonce les portes,
contredis les mauvaises langues,
ose hausser la voix, ose dire qui tu es,
ta culture, tes différences,
ta singularité.
Et c’est cette attitude combative
qui vient jouer un mauvais tour
au fatalisme du déterminisme.
C'est la détermination.
Vous me direz : « Tanya, c’est bien beau.
La détermination s’est moquée
du déterminisme et so what ? »
Mettons les cartes sur table.
Voilà ce que j’ai appliqué
et que j’aurais aimé qu’on me dise.
Tout d’abord, apprends à t’aimer,
joue de la carte « Amour de soi ».
Oui, j’ai dû tout d’abord
apprendre à m’aimer,
apprendre à m’aimer pour outrepasser
toutes ces questions de valeurs.
C’est peut-être plus facile
pour certains que pour d’autres.
Mais il faut se le répéter chaque jour :
« Je m’aime.
J’ai de la valeur. »
Et ce, jusqu’à en être convaincu.
Je me souviens m’être dit souvent,
et pas dans un excès de narcissisme :
« Je m’aime pour toutes les personnes
qu’il y a sur cette Terre. »
J'avais onze ans.
Je venais de subir
des moqueries, du racisme.
Mais il était hors de question que
je cède aux sirènes du laisser-aller,
du « Je laisse tomber »,
« Je ne vaux rien »,
« Ils ont raison ».
Non, ça ne m’atteint pas, moi.
Ça ne m’atteint pas.
Ça ne nous atteint pas parce que
nous nous répétons chaque jour :
« Je m’aime.
J’ai de la valeur.
Je m’aime pour toutes les personnes
qu’il y a sur cette Terre. »
Après tout,
être différent ne signifie pas
avoir plus ou moins de valeur.
Réfléchissons ensemble.
Quel est l’antonyme de « différent » ?
Est-ce « égal » ?
Non, ce n’est pas « égal », son antonyme,
c’est « identique ».
Rien à voir avec une question de valeur.
Souvent, je reprends ma fille quand elle
ne veut pas finir son assiette et me dit :
« Maman, ce n’est pas bon. »
Je la reprends et je lui dis :
« Ma chérie, ne me dis pas
que ce n’est pas bon.
Dis que tu n’aimes pas. »
Pas vous ?
En gros, « ne remets pas
la qualité nutritive des épinards,
la valeur des épinards, juste parce que
c’est différent du goût des pâtes
et qu’accessoirement,
tu n’aimes pas ce goût. »
Bref, cette comparaison exprime bien
mon point de vue sur la différence.
Je vous propose d’associer
cette carte de la différence
avec la carte « acceptation de soi ».
J'entends par là s'assumer.
Je vous ai parlé
de mes 23 frères et sœurs.
Hyper pratique pour éviter les sujets
complexes en entretien, mais pas que.
Derrière ma vie bien rangée
de banlieusarde parisienne,
je peux me la couler douce -
vivons caché, vivons heureux,
postons sur Instagram de belles images.
Mais entre nous, à quoi cela me sert
si ce n’est que de complexer
ceux qui ne se retrouvent pas
dans ces images d’Épinal ?
Alors que le simple fait
de s’afficher tel qu’on est
peut lever tellement de doutes
et permettre à d’autres d’être moins
complexés et de reprendre confiance.
Alors, rencontrons-nous.
Misons sur la carte rencontre de l'autre.
J'ai eu la chance, plus jeune, de faire
une très très belle rencontre.
J’intervenais
en zone d’éducation prioritaire.
J’étais étudiante, une anonyme
et je faisais un peu de soutien
scolaire et autres activités.
Et j'ai croisé cette petite fille.
J’ai longtemps échangé sur mon parcours
et ce sans mon masque
de l’étudiante d’école parisienne.
Et vous savez quoi ? Elle s’est prise
d’affection, voire d’admiration pour moi.
Mais pourquoi ?
Je ne suis pas Beyoncé.
Eh bien parce qu’elle
s’est reconnue en moi.
Une jeune femme qui, comme elle,
n’était pas née au bon endroit,
dans les meilleures conditions,
mais qui avait su se frayer un chemin dans
un monde qui lui paraissait inaccessible.
« Si Tania est là, pourquoi pas moi ? »
Je vous en fais la confidence,
elle m’a donné envie d’agir à mon échelle.
Je dirais même plus,
elle m’a éclairée et permis d’admettre
que nous pouvons tous
être des rôles modèles.
Tout simplement,
en levant le voile sur son histoire,
en racontant son histoire.
Racontez-vous.
Racontez ce qui a jalonné votre parcours.
Et pas seulement
le côté visible de l’iceberg.
L’Invisible mérite d’être découvert
et le tout peut être fort utile
et inspirant pour d’autres.
Vraiment inspirant pour d'autres.
Est-ce que vous voulez savoir -
on parle d’inspiration là -
ce qui moi m’a inspirée ?
Quelle a été ma carte Inspiration ?
Si vous ne dites pas oui,
j’ai un problème,
je ne peux pas continuer.
Donc là on dit oui, d’accord ?
Alors, ma carte Inspiration ?
Les Feux de l’amour.
Non, j’ai dit que je m’assumais :
les Feux de l’amour.
Petite, je regardais
cette série avec Maman.
Et je rêvais des tailleurs étroits et des
brushing XXL de ses personnages féminins.
Mais comment, moi, petite fille de couleur
d’une classe sociale plus que modeste,
j’allais faire pour entrer dans ce monde ?
Toc, toc toc, la porte des élites,
laissez-moi entrer.
On est d’accord, c’est compliqué.
Mais je savais que,
pour y parvenir, pour réussir,
il fallait que je comprenne
comment ça marche.
Il fallait que je prenne
cet ascenseur social.
Et vous savez quoi ?
Cet ascenseur,
il est accessible par l’éducation,
l’école, les études.
Alors j’ai redoublé d’efforts
pour apprendre à parler
ce langage des grands hommes,
ou du moins les imiter.
Et je crois bien que j'ai réussi.
J’ai grimpé cette interminable échelle :
bac scientifique, prépa, école,
gros contrats et tailleur brushing.
(Rires)
Eh oui, mais comment avais-je compris
tout ça dès le plus jeune âge ?
C’est simple.
Une fois que j’ai visualisé
là où je voulais être,
tout simplement demandé mon chemin.
Il n'y a pas plus simple.
Il n’y a pas de honte
à poser des questions.
Il n’y a pas de mauvaises questions.
Jouons-la, notre carte de la curiosité.
Ça me rappelle une anecdote
perso, plutôt pro.
Je travaillais
sur une présentation importante
et, faute de temps,
je n’ai pas vérifié mes sources.
J’ai mis comme source « BAO ».
Je fais ma présentation, et la question :
« Que signifie BAO ? »
Gênée, j’explique la situation :
« Bouche à oreille. »
Toute l’assemblée avait sa réponse
et n’avait plus besoin
de faire semblant de connaître
ce nom du grand organisme de conseil
que j’avais inventé de toutes pièces.
Merci, chers collègues,
d’avoir posé la question.
On peut y aller.
Je voulais revenir à la carte Chance.
Ah, la chance.
J’ai parlé beaucoup de chance,
mais cette fois-ci,
je vous propose de parler
de la carte Chance du Monopoly.
Vous savez, celle où on peut
bien piocher en carte Chance :
« Jour de paye »,
« Carte Prison ».
Je vous propose de faire comme au Monopoly
et de considérer que la carte Prison
est une carte Chance.
Ça titille votre curiosité...
Bon, je vais vous dire, je lisais
un article sur les réseaux sociaux
et il m’a interpellée.
Il disait qu’il fallait remercier
les personnes qui nous ont mis
des bâtons dans les roues.
Les personnes qui n’ont pas cru en nous.
Ah ? Vraiment, là ? Il faut ?
Mais en l’appliquant sur mon parcours,
effectivement, ces personnes-là
constituent de très belles rencontres.
L’une de mes premières rencontres
avec la discrimination
a été ma maîtresse de maternelle.
Si elle m’écoute aujourd’hui,
j’aimerais la remercier.
Car grâce à elle, grâce au fait
qu’elle m’ait mise à l’écart,
j’étais motivée à faire des études.
J’étais motivée
à lui prouver, à me prouver,
que, peu importe mon origine,
peu importe ma naissance,
peu importe ma classe sociale,
peu importe tout,
je vais y arriver et j’irai le plus
loin possible dans les études.
Et c’est comme ça que,
dès l’âge de cinq ans,
je me suis donné comme objectif de faire
de très, très, très longues études.
Et j'ai réussi.
Impensable à l'époque.
Cette maîtresse m’a challengée
et m’a donné le goût des études.
Je vous propose de faire une pause.
Pensez à votre carte Chance,
à votre rencontre chance.
Accordons-lui, là,
ici et maintenant, trois secondes
et vous allez la remercier.
On y va.
Merci.
Apaisant, non ?
Le monde est injuste et il est ainsi fait.
Et alors ?
Le groupe IAM chante -
alors c’est fini, la chanson, pour moi -
« Personne ne joue
avec les mêmes cartes. »
Je ne dis pas que
les miennes étaient les pires.
Non, ce n'est pas le but
de mon intervention.
Je ne suis pas là pour vous exhiber
le château que j’ai fait avec mes cartes.
J’en suis très fière, oui,
mais je sais aussi qu’il est fragile,
que rien n’est acquis.
Mais c’est aussi cette fragilité
qui en fait sa beauté.
Je suis là pour vous montrer que
vous avez toutes les cartes en main,
aussi mauvaises qu’elles
puissent vous paraître.
L'essentiel est bien souvent
invisible pour les yeux.
Ouvrez-les un peu plus pour apercevoir
votre essentiel personnel,
pour trouver votre équilibre.
Entre nous,
ne vous êtes-vous jamais demandé quelles
étaient les cartes de votre voisin ?
Tout semble lui réussir à lui,
mais à quel critère correspond-il ?
Auquel ne correspond-il pas ?
On s’en fait tout un monde.
J’ai l’intime conviction que
personne n’a le jeu de cartes parfait.
Allez, je vous donne un défi.
Demain, demandez à votre voisin
de vous dévoiler son jeu de cartes.
Et vous verrez qu’avec ses cartes,
qu’avec vos cartes, qu’avec nos cartes,
nous avons tout en main pour construire
le château dans lequel nous rêvons d’être.
Tu peux aussi être
cette rencontre éclairante,
ce petit raz-de-marée
qui fait déborder sur les vies
des flots de bienveillance.
Ces petits coups de pouce qui n'ont l'air
de rien, mais qui peuvent tout changer.
C’est pourquoi je te propose
d’être à notre tour
cette petite voix
qui répétera sans cesse :
« Vas-y, fonce, sois fier de toi !
Ta singularité est ta force,
et non ton fardeau.
C’est OK de penser out of the box,
c’est OK de te battre
pour qui tu veux être.
C'est OK de te lever et de tout casser.
Tu as de la valeur.
Ne laisse personne
te convaincre du contraire.
Construis de tes cartes
le plus solide des châteaux personnels.
Fais de ta vie une ode à la détermination,
à l’audace, à la chance, aux rencontres,
à l’authenticité, à l’assurance,
à la pensée positive. »
Car après tout, notre point de départ
ne détermine pas notre point d’arrivée.
(Applaudissements)